we figured that if we can get this group
of kids excited about vegetables and
gardening and that we might be able to
take that nationwide teaching kids to
garden and eat their vegetables now
there's a classic first lady project but
local governments across the nation have
taken a more forceful tact an extra 12
cents on a can of soda with raised
nearly 1 billion dollars whether it's
San Francisco banning Happy Meal toys
New York targeting salt or most recently
South LA permanently banning new
fast-food restaurants all together
fast-food restaurants had the ability to
come into our community and buy right
build stores Los Angeles City Councilman
Bernard parks says there are simply too
many fast-food restaurants in his
district about 70% of our restaurants
are fast-food minimal - no restaurants
sit-down restaurants or alternative food
sources a fast-food restaurant which is
defined as one with pre-made dishes and
a limited menu cannot open in the eighth
or ninth districts if one tries to do so
parks or councilmember Jan Perry will
deny approval of its business permits
still parks bristles at the word ban
we've never had a ban that we have a
process that requires they can no longer
go by right so there's no banned gonna
give the community options other than
fast food
we hope that giving options of less
fried food and incentives to bring in
grocery stores that bring fresh fruits
and vegetables and non processed food
that we're going to make an impact on
the health and welfare of the community
will this non bans of fast food improve
the health and welfare of South LA as
residents people single out fast food
because of what I refer to as the health
nuts out there
Chaz Weaver a fitness and weight loss
consultant in Huntington Beach is
skeptical now I'm a proponent that you
can live a healthy life as long as is in
moderation Weaver knows a thing or two
about fast food he produced and starred
in a documentary called downsize me
Morgan Spurlock's Iowa
you hate McDonald's every single day and
generally about six meals a day but
unlike Morgan Spurlock's McDonald's
binge Weavers 30-day experiment didn't
float her endanger him people think that
if you eat McDonald's all said it's so
unhealthy you're gonna deteriorate
yourself not only did I lose eight
pounds of body fat I maintain my health
and fitness level and even if you don't
work out as much as Weaver does he says
it's still okay to eat fast food you can
eat a moderate lifestyle some fast food
some healthy food things that you like
is long it's in moderation it's not
going to deteriorate you go into your
chain restaurants your IHOP's your TGI
Fridays your claim jumpers now while I
do eat at those restaurants I have
nothing against them whatsoever but most
sometimes have far more calories and
you're gonna find it a fast-food
restaurant
parks does seem to recognize that people
can make unhealthy choices even when not
eating at in-and-out burger or KFC
grocery stores not selling anything more
healthy in mini instances in the fast
food restaurant so if you can get
unhealthy food at Trader Joe's or
California Pizza Kitchen and you can get
healthy food at McDonald's or Wendy's
why single out fast food if you go to
any community meeting in South Los
Angeles in the 8th district and bring up
the fact of fast food restaurants you
get an overwhelming nod that there are
too many of them but not everyone living
in parks district thinks that there are
too many fast-food restaurants I'm
Jeremy Langford
and we are at the burger stand Crenshaw
and Jefferson you can come through
anytime get you some nice home-cooked
food
Jeremy and his mother run the restaurant
which is right down the street from
Parks's office I don't think there could
ever be so many fast-food places they're
still buying it their choices are driven
by what people bring as opposed to what
may be better for them and in an order
the forced choice into the market we
have to limit one that's over
concentrated and attract others that
provide other options the idea that you
can create more choices by reducing
choices I think is a little bit
self-refuting Matt Welch is the SoCal
native and
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine but
our parks is punishing the people who
are willing to do business in South LA
you will get people to come into your
neighborhood when they feel like your
neighborhood can support their business
and that the climate to do business in
that neighborhood is positive period the
fact is there are fewer fast-food
restaurants per capita in South LA than
there are in West LA or in LA County
overall it's just that there are fewer
restaurants of any kind someone may have
a wonderful idea to bring in a fast-food
restaurant at a certain location yet
there's three on the other three corners
and we could sit down and say you may
want to think about another type
business because we're not going to add
to the over concentration we might
discourage business people from going
into a certain type of business we have
too many barbershops side by side we
hear the complaints we can be we have
too many WIC shops side by side to let
the community to side which is what
Barnard Park says needs to happen the
best way to do that is to stop rules
that prevent natural choices from being
made this neighborhood particularly
likes this service let the residents buy
what they want to and if people want a
quick cheap meal are they really going
to replace it with a trip to a sit-down
restaurant or a grocery store the busy
lives we go to work we can't we have no
time to get up coach breakfast in the
morning got to run go to a drive-through
and go to work and while it's easy to
take shots at Taco Bell and Carl's jr.
what about small businessmen like Jeremy
the biggest things that politicians
misunderstand about small business
owners is I don't know if they have our
own one but it's very hard this is a big
accomplishment for us to have a place
like this and it was so much hard work
we get our hands dirty and for them to
try to determine what we should do or
shouldn't do without ever being a part
of it it's kind of hard because this is
how
living and Jeremy's little burger stand
alone employs ten people in a city with
an unemployment rate far higher than the
national average it feels good that I'd
be able to give somebody a job there's a
guy walking around you know he doesn't
have any money he's like man can I clean
up for you guys you know I give him the
power to do that and then he ended up
coming every night and that's a guy who
does it being better put together you
know he dresses nicer another thing like
that I was just glad I was able to give
him a chance and I don't think we can
make that argument about unemployment
over health of the community the
camellias right they have input as to
what they believe is in over
concentration for the time being the
first lady has limited most of her
efforts to educating children the goal
is to make sure that kids grow up
healthy eating well and living better
and longer but local politicians in
South LA and around the country continue
striving to alter everyone's eating
habits we are being treated as children
and I don't think it's right you have to
train people as to what may be
beneficial to them honestly none of
their business
we know what we're eating I don't think
politicians should be able to tell
somebody what to eat how much to
exercise it's a free country we should
be able to eat what we want to